well this is a tough video to make it's
a tough video to make and and earlier in
the week it really looked like we were
going to be able to persevere
but um
it's it's over
I'm going to be leaving YouTube just
leaving leaving everything the Stu I
have to film like this because the
Studio's already being taken down we're
taking the sound panels off the walls
next and everything
um we lost all our advertisers all of
our new members canceled and
everybody's leaving YouTube and it just
it sucks it sucks you know uh if you saw
this week there's like they sent the mob
after me and Hannity and Don Jr and
Candace Owens they all went crazy they
went after me
and I got canceled
so you know maybe I'll be able to get on
like some I don't know some other
platform or something like that but like
this is kind of it and it sucks I have
to even film it like this I don't even
have my studio the toilets aren't even
flushing at the studio although I guess
that has something to do with Biden I
don't I don't know we're having to flush
10 to 15 times but it I just
everything's going wrong is the point
and it's sad I really wish we could have
gone out at the top
but this is it all right guys so we'll
see you around and it's just
it just sucks